[Music]
Eerie resurrection's mysterious
characters and record-breaking
performances are all a part of James
Cameron's long-awaited sequel Avatar the
way of water he is everything you need
to know about this sequel that's a
decade in the making the last two
feature directorial efforts from James
Cameron Titanic and Avatar both excelled
at the box office largely thanks to
opening just before Christmas weekend it
was a perfect date for countless reasons
including how it allowed these movies to
flourish over multiple holidays and to
play into January a month often devoid
of other big Blockbusters it's no wonder
that Avatar the way of water is taking a
cue from Cameron's previous films in its
release date The massive Blockbuster
will begin playing in movie theaters
everywhere on December 16 2022 back in
2010 when the Avatar sequels were just
being laid out James Cameron announced
ambition to get the first of these
follow-ups into theaters by December
2014. the process of writing the movies
arduous enough to necessitate a move to
December 2017. before Disney settled on
a December 2021 release date the movie
wasn't finished shifting around the
calendar though the covid-19 pandemic
would cause one more delay until its
final December 2022 release date though
it took so long to stick to an opening
date the way of water appears fully on
track for a December 2022 premiere fans
will be happy to know that Jake Surly
and naturi will return for Avatar the
way of water both characters Remain the
protagonist of the sequel the secrecy
surrounding Avatar the way of water
means there isn't a lot of information
about the character's stories though
however one big change for the pair
that's been confirmed is that the duo
will now have multiple children to take
care of this family is our Fortress in
2017 Sam Worthington noted that this
aspect of Jake and natiri would be
critical to the way of water a central
theme of the movie is family according
to the actor Worthington also expressed
excitement over the expanded scope of
the movie and noted that this
Blockbuster will be delivering an
unprecedented spectacle to moviegoers
for her part Zoe Saldana conveyed her
excitement for this follow-up by
revealing to People magazine that she
was moved to tears after watching
footage from the way of water even if
concrete details about Jake and the
Theory's respective Journeys are still
shrouded in mystery the actors who
portray the I'm sure sound enthusiastic
about everything this movie has to offer
in the original Avatar Sigourney Weaver
played the human being Dr Grace
Augustine a character who perishes
despite a last-ditch effort from her
friends to transport her soul into her
Avatar body though such a definitive
death would seem to have cut off any
opportunity for Weaver to show up in
avatar The Way of water it was confirmed
as early as September 2011 that she
would indeed be coming back for the
sequel things became even more
intriguing in 2015 when on the Jonathan
Ross show Weaver revealed that she would
be playing someone brand new in an
avatar sequel after years of speculation
Weaver's concrete role in the movie was
revealed Weaver will be playing Jake and
the tiri's adopted teenage Nabi daughter
Kiri the concept of Weaver playing such
a young character may sound baffling but
Weaver was well up to the challenge
explaining to Empire I think we all
pretty much remember what we were
feeling as adolescents I certainly do I
was 5 foot 10 of 5 foot 11 when I I was
11. I felt strongly that Kyrie would
feel awkward a lot of the time she's
searching for who she is I was thrilled
to be given that challenge by Jim the
universe of Avatar is so full of
surprises and few are shocking as Hal
Sigourney Weaver is coming back for
Avatar the way of water
Steven Lang left an enormous impression
of moviegoers in his performance as a
nefarious human villain miles courage
you got that
damn across the line
he despise the navi natives of Pandora
and went to many extreme lens to pull
off his mission at the end of Avatar it
seemed like his story had drawn to a
close thanks to natiri plunging two
massive arrows into his chest however as
early as 2013 James Cameron made it
clear that he had major plans for
courage in the assorted Avatar sequels
death was not the end for this adversary
but rather the beginning of a whole new
plotline Avatar the way of water will
seek Warwick returning in a navi body as
part of a program called recombinence
AKA avatars and carry the consciousness
of dead soldiers though he retains his
memories from his human form this
incarnation of quarrych has some new
abilities to make him an extra
formidable presence for the film's
heroes Lang said to Empire he was always
a character who moved in straight lines
and at right angles but now he is his
life as they come he can move with the
same kind of cunning and feral quality
that any of the navi can after
collaborating on Titanic Kate Winslet
and James Cameron are working together
again again in avatar The Way of water
winds let down the motion capture suit
for the sequel to play ronal one of the
leaders of the meccaena tribe a
collection of Navi who live in the
oceans of Pandora Winslet has some
insights about the character when she
spoke to Empire she is strong a warrior
even in the face of grave danger and
with an unborn baby on board she still
joins her people and fights for what she
holds most dear her family and their
home to portray ronal winsletout to film
many of her scenes underwater doing this
required her to learn how to hold her
breath for prolonged periods of time
Winslet eventually got so good at it
that she was able to hold her breath for
7 minutes and 14 seconds this feed the
throne to Tom Cruise's work in Mission
Impossible Rogue Nation for the record
of the longest breath hold while
shooting a movie underwater
Avatar the way of water is chock full of
actors who played characters that died
in the first film most are either coming
back in new bodies or are playing brand
new characters altogether but there's an
extended shelf life for nearly all the
performers of the original Avatar a key
exception to this though is Michelle
Rodriguez who played the pilot Trudy in
the original film her character perished
in the climactic Battle of Avatar
getting wiped out by General courage's
warship while the Fantastical world of
Avatar would seem to deliver plenty of
avenues for resurrecting Trudy Rodriguez
has long confirmed she wouldn't be
involved in the way of water
Rogue one is hit going in
sorry Jake the loss of Trudy may be
discouraging for fans of the first
avatar but at least Avatar the way of
water won't be sure some brand new human
characters to help the otherworldly
protagonists James Cameron has continued
to heat praser Rodriguez in recent years
including saying that her Resident Evil
performance is a key reason why he
considers that video game adaptation a
guilty pleasure favorite fans of the
original Avatar will be pleased to see
so many familiar faces returning for
Avatar the way of water this includes
Joel David Moore who play Pandora expert
Norm Spellman in the original Avatar
meanwhile CCH Pounder is also confirmed
to be coming back as moat the mother of
nadiri while dalip Rao is returning as
human scientist Dr Max Patel the
presence of these faces ensures that
Jake Surly and madeiri will have plenty
of trustworthy allies in their midst as
they contend with dark Forces to sending
on Pandora there will also be villains
from the original feature coming back
for the follow-up one of the most
notable returning antagonists is
Giovanni with BC as Parker Selfridge who
previously served as a major advocate
for rda's interest in mining Pandora's
resources meanwhile audiences may have
seen him get trampled to death in the
first avatar but Matt Gerald is still
returning as Corporal Lyle Wayne Fleet
the Castro Avatar the way of water is
heavy on brand new characters with many
of them being children or teenagers as
part of this movie's indication of how
long it's been since the first avatar
took place there's a whole new
generation of human and Navi characters
the audiences to discover there are
several younger characters introduced in
the sequel including a trio of
youngsters netayam loac and tukutiri
Jake and the tiri's children there is
also a human teenager Javier who's in
love with the biological world of
Pandora as for the new grown-ups in the
story Cliff Curtis is on hand to portray
tonawari one of the leaders of the
mechaina people while Edie Falco is
portraying General Ardmore a human who
handles rda's Ambitions for the planet
Pandora Jermaine Clement is on board to
portray marine biologist Dr Ian Garvin
while another Medical Professional Dr
Karina Moog will be played by Michelle
yo then there's Oona Chaplin who is
portraying varang a figure who plays an
important role in avatar The Way of
water and all of its successes the
character is shrouded in such secrecy
that is still alone if she's a human or
a member of the navi people
while there haven't been further Avatar
movies in between the original film in
2009 and Avatar the way of water that
doesn't mean his franchise has been in
hibernation for over a decade Avatar has
continued to leave a footprint on pop
culture thanks to Pandora the world of
Avatar a land in Animal Kingdom at the
Walt Disney World Resort that opened in
May 2017. the location allowed the
general public to get closer to the
finer details of Pandora than ever
before given its popularity it shouldn't
be a surprise that the way of water will
find ways to acknowledge all that this
spark has contributed to the Mythos of
Avatar it's about reconnecting an
audience with that almost childlike
wonder and appreciation that you have
for the natural world talking to inside
the magic producer John Lando noted that
the Avatar ride flight of Passage
featured the first hints of the oceans
of Pandora a landscape that will be
explored in Greater detail in the way of
water he also hinted that some of the
creatures introduced in the flight of
Passage ride could make their way into
the way of War and other Avatar sequels
additionally he mentioned that new Mech
suits that walked around the Avatar Land
at Animal Kingdom were inspired by
designs for these outfits that will be
used in avatar The Way of water these
share details between the Avatar theme
park attractions and movies provides
some exciting hints of what moviegoers
can expect from the way of water
in 2009 Avatar changed a game for
digital 3D it wasn't the first movie to
be presented in the format but it was
the one that got everybody to see the
potential for digital 3D cinema in the
years since Avatar dominated the box
office though moviegoers and Studios
have fallen out of love with digital 3D
the shrinking presence of the formats
might lead one to wonder if Avatar the
way of water will take a cue from
domestic IMAX locations and leave 3D
behind however James Cameron has opted
to remain loyal to this projection
method by guaranteeing that Avatar the
way of water will be released in this
format too not only that but Cameron is
using technological advances to further
improve digital 3D projection while
talking at the Busan International Film
Festival Cameron noted that the way of
water would be sporadically employing a
higher than usual frame rate during
certain spectacle heavy sequences that
will help improve the quality of the
digital 3D images it's safe to say that
audiences can expect an extremely
thoughtful return to the world of
digital 3D cinema with Avatar the way of
water the finer blood details of Avatar
the way of water have been kept close to
the chest and run up to the movie's
release from a plot synopsis on the
film's official website the movie will
take place over a decade after the
original Avatar it broadly talks about
how this sequel will Chronicle all kinds
of turmoil Jake they Theory and their
family will face as well as how they try
to protect one another beyond the
details outlined here the way of water
is confirmed to largely take place
across Pandora's expansive oceans a
backdrop that will help to introduce
many of the stories new characters as
for the villains of the way of water
they should be familiar to anyone who
loves the original Avatar the evil
organization resources development
Administration will make a return to
server surveillance of the way of water
the twists go around is that the plot of
the way of water will see the RDA
implant the spirits of dead soldiers
into Navi bodies to create creatures
called recombinants other New pieces of
Technology like a massive 3d printing
plans will allow RDA to terrorize the
heroes of the way of water while many of
the story details about this sequel are
shrouded in mystery what has been
revealed suggests an epic scope and lots
of action are in store for fans
[Music]